hello freak [ __ ] I would also like to
see a super heavyweight division I would
like to see a full-on freak show I want
to see the mountain from Game of Thrones
I want to see that guy learn how to
fight you say 330 [ __ ] pounds you
know that God it picks up those stone
balls and [ __ ] do you know I'm talking
about carries cars he's one of those
dudes how big is he jeong inhye solid
six eight oh my god yeah
Viking strait Viking long hair and beard
no he's got beard yeah he's like one of
those Iceland guys I think Sweden or
Iceland one of them one of them Viking
characters how big is that mountain dude
there's a video of him sparring with
Conor McGregor it's hilarious he's six
foot nine Jesus Christ what in the [ __ ]
is that there a picture of him Jesus
Christ
he weighs 380 pounds 380 of him picking
up cars oh yeah there's a bunch of
videos of him doing [ __ ] here watch him
that's him see if they have some videos
of him doing his workouts his workouts
are [ __ ] insane or in some sort of a
strongman competition gypsy go back go
back to the screen you just had so you
can scroll down to that Conor McGregor
video the screen you just had that's it
right there
see conor mcgregor vs the mountain like
only holy [ __ ] and Connor is playing
around with them sparring with them look
at the size of this guy and Connie's
like slapping them in the stomach he's
like come on I'm gonna grab you you try
to grab them
dude oh look at this he's like come on
man he's looking him a high-five yeah
he's been tired he's getting tired
damn kinda wanted to keep going look
he's totally no English she's got a mad
yeah I got a mad this is real night oh
yeah it's getting real how old is this
it's pretty recent like before he fought
all done yeah look at this gun tricks a
whole stick he's just kidding I do a
straight laughs my god thanks he's mad
yeah he's mad dude ha ha ha
this is why Conor McGregor's such a bad
[ __ ] he's so he's so crazy like
legitimately crazy dude he's like Bruce
Lee
he's just popping that guy in the
stomach with those straight left's and
he don't like it and he knows that dudes
getting tired look he's like he threw
his kicks
dude look he's spinning in his leg
together inside his crotch she was
getting him too old could you just pick
up Connor if you wanted to oh never
front kicked him in the body oh [ __ ]
he's just teeing off on and he's moving
to do get hired he's so big
cuz I think that [ __ ] I'd kick him
right now he keeps popping in with that
straight left look at that this is crazy
because this goes for a few minutes man
I guarantee that dude is not doing a
whole lot oh he's getting tired man look
at him he's backing up big giant
six-foot what what is a 6-9 6-9 386
getting tired he's trying to grab him
nope nope not today's her ha ha he's
laughing his bhava is that is like dude
he was that was like a Bruce Lee laughs
yeah ok this is real so you look at ol
over no we're gonna keep popping him
with that straight left it's funny man
it's weird to watch right he tried to
give him a high-five to stop the hunter
said ah yeah
Oh tagged him he's throwing yeah if it's
not into that none to that oh dude yeah
you don't get that oh oh oh he doesn't
like it
those are hard shots he gave up see me
oh god I see them like oh [ __ ] wow that
was a really clear real fight I was a
half-elf I
[Applause]
[Music]